foreign
folks here we are we might be drunk
we're back it's the summertime in New
York City how you feeling I'm rough man
travel rode hard put away with it yeah
you know what happened I was uh
all flights canceled yesterday in New
York it's one of those here's a peeve
out of the gate I got a quick pee for
you if you're on the phone with uh
you're on the phone with Airlines and
all the flights are canceled and you're
like well I gotta get back at this time
I'm Gonna Miss This podcast so I have to
take a 6 a.m flight and then that got
delayed the 6 a.m delay is the biggest
peeve there is because you get up early
and you're like if you time it you're
like if I got like a window where I
could still fall asleep yeah you know so
you're like because you look in your
phone your eyes are [__] and you you
can't fall back asleep oh I've been
there I know it too well so uh that gets
delayed a flight attendant just didn't
show up what the
what's happening in this country What's
going
[Music]
on I wish they did wish they did sleep
yeah that one's true good but you know
uh
I'm on the phone with the guy yesterday
and he hits me with this where I go okay
well I'm I'm not taking I cancel my
flight
I'm going to take another airlocks I
need to get in for this podcast yeah and
and he goes I was able to make the
cancellation
oh well good job
[__] [__] yeah I would hope you
will you [__] me yeah exactly I hate
the rebook on a flight that [__] you
yeah they act like our heroes we
rebooked you on a 5 a.m connect flight
that's what they rebooked me on yeah
yeah
get a customer service queefs is you
ever fight with them and they go all
right fine I'll do it and you're like so
you could have done it but you have to
give me the pushback for three hours but
then they give in and they cave and
you're like now I know you're full of
[__] oh it's the worst well luckily I
have really good agents who booked me in
Texas in July so I got to spend an extra
day there uh I'm sure it was uh cool
weather oh it was like a hundred plus oh
it's crazy brutal that's that's my goal
weight that's horrible it's brutal it's
it's wild down there it's the wild wild
west where you were in the city though I
was in the city living easy did some
gigs all over town great time yeah yeah
I'm running I'm trying to run some new
stuff so I'm doing like an hour in
Jersey I'm doing a seller hour I'm doing
an hour in Queens I'm really just
calling favors yeah and now we're in
Queens that's rough yeah it sounds like
a Spike Lee movie an hour in Queens
we're on like opposite ends of our hours
right now because I'm like getting to a
place I'm like yeah it's almost good
enough to shoot but not quite yet but uh
wow that's quick quick turnover yeah a
year and a half well I guess with the
special came out what six months ago
five months ago
last September oh [__] has it been that
long yeah geez it's flying time flies
because there's so many [__] specials
that's true they don't feel special no
no God no they really don't yeah
speaking of which I got one coming out
and then uh in a little bit is it not
out right now July 25th it comes out
hey check it out July 25th Netflix
whatever time they do what's the title
Soup To Nuts because we cover everything
Soup To Nuts I would have gone with an
hour in Queens but that's fine
yeah well I was in Chicago but I'll take
it but it looks I saw the intro already
it looks amazing thank you thank you
little boy James Webb directed it Webb
killed it cats killed it uh chasing cats
oh good time I had veter open I had will
so Vince hosting uh the wife came out
friends came out Vic theater killer time
I love it yeah I'm doing the Chicago
Theater September 30th oh my God yeah
that's a legendary spot I'm pumped wow
that's a beauty for Schumer there years
ago I couldn't believe it here's I got
another piece I'm coming with [__]
pieces I post a video they asked for a
promo video for Chicago yeah love
Chicago I'm like even excited to make
the promo video there you go so I do a
whole thing where I'm like the joke is I
guess I make you know Chicago you know
home of Wrigley deep dish pizza
in a in a shooting epidemic you can't
get a lid on you know and then I go wait
a second that third one's bad well I got
a good one for you Sam Morel Chicago
Theater September uh 30th yeah
Facebook Flags this oh my lord they're
like you can't make a shooting joke I'm
like but you can buy the guns oh I can't
make a [__] joke about the guns but
you can get the guns good point well at
least you got a bit out of it that's
gonna be a bit maybe yeah so it makes me
crazy it's like it worries me like when
people talk about like cancel culture
[__] I'm like I hate there's nothing
more boring than talking about that [__]
but when you talk about it and you're
like all right I don't care about people
but it's a social media company yeah
let's scare the [__] out of me it's some
douchey robot going shooting shooting
you know
which is how I [__] but uh I'm like they
don't even know there's no context like
you get the nerd out here going hey you
shouldn't say that I'm like well at
least there you can talk to them the
computer's just [__] there's no
reasoning it's bad it's bad for the
future because that's like it is it's
how guys like us got fans right is
through this [__] and we had jokes that
like boarded on the line because that's
how we make jokes there's nothing lameer
than having to work within these
restrictions yeah you feel like the
teacher's pet like I'll do a clean joke
right and if you're already clean fine
but that's not how we are it's not how
we think exactly and context matters
like with The Tonight Show they're
pretty rigid but you can at least go no
no boner I'd say boner it's very silly
and they're like all right fine we'll
give you a boner but you got to take out
homo and you're gonna take a 12 year old
I'll take a few of those out but yeah so
you can at least banter but the also the
internet was where we went to go be
ourselves and now the internet's getting
queefy that's what sucks and the and the
awful thing is Twitter is the least
restrictive that's fine it's also kind
of the worst for sharing video stuff
Twitter's kind of become lame too
because if you just post a joke on
Twitter first off no one really does
anymore I feel like it's so much just
like I guess doing it so yeah I mean
it's just then the attackers there's so
many Hall monitors there yes exactly I
tell I said it before I did a joke about
Alzheimer's and I got like eight million
tweets like that's insensitive and I was
like get a grip huh okay they didn't
like that but uh yeah it's just like
it's an also not Alzheimer's sorry
what's the one arthritis arthritis
that's okay all right I said I did an
arthritis joke and I got all these like
hey that's a bliss and all that and I
was like I didn't get a grip and they
didn't love that ableist is such a
ridiculous
I always think of the Michael Che joke
it's like you being offended you know on
behalf on behalf yeah of others like
that to me that's the most privileged
[__] in the world yeah good point but uh
yeah good old Shea Che Guevara but uh
yeah so that was annoying but although I
did do shows and I did two at the
Paramount in Denver which were unreal uh
that's a great room great room great uh
great town great town we didn't get to
see much of it because you know we got
in a day early another flight problem
three hours on the [__] Runway we
missed the days of Sully give me Sully
again you know just call him in when a
flight attendant doesn't do show up but
you know what we got lucky because I
don't know if you heard about that [__]
at Red Rocks but it was like it was
handling the size of baseballs that was
my opener I said and the Rockies still
wouldn't be able to hit it but uh you
know it was handling the size of [__]
baseballs and people getting injured
whoa was it a gay band it was actually
uh the guy's name was Louis Tom omelets
and I found out uh Taylor's dead no it
was uh from One Direction oh okay yeah
yeah that was another line I said
something about uh finally uh finally
finally a different Louis got canceled
these are great things you got off of
gotta come out with the local [__] yeah
hail Hitler all right that's all I got
out of it we went different roads you
know where Hitler's coming from well you
got the hail okay uh hayla cab there you
go I cleaned it up but then uh yeah
Denver's kill dude I've never been to
Santa Fe awesome place I don't think
I've ever been there I've been there
either never done comedy there and I'll
say this best crowd of the whole [__]
weekend really Denver was great Santa Fe
was my favorite they were just electric
man is that New Mexico yeah yeah wow I
think it's the capital
Albuquerque maybe or is it Santa Fe what
is it I don't know give it a good but oh
never been to Santa Fe I've been all
over this you'll go this country I'm
down bring it on and then and then hit
San Antonio and Houston oh Phoenix I'm
an idiot
wait that's Arizona no that's not the
capital
of New Mexico New Mexico
people in the comments calling us idiots
already it's Santa Fe right
apples
yeah real Hit or Miss capitals yeah I
think it's like a rich town I think like
oh really I think uh one of the sacklers
has a place there it's like real like
Rich got it uh like it's got like Aspen
Vibes oh yeah yeah a lot of Jade a lot
of hot moms in those jackets with the
the dangly things hot Native American
women oh really yeah oh it blows I'll
give a [__] go give her a cocktail
okay I was worried I was gonna get
heckled and get a comedian get scalped
the video but we'll see I hear some San
Antonio one of the best Mexican food
spots oh I've been in the country for
sure yeah a lot of adobe oh yeah Adobe
Premiere well I gotta run this by you
please
went to my first Jewish wedding really
over the weekend Broken Glass Broken
Glass the chair up you know uh what do
you call that thing where you you turn
the Dance Floor you spin in a circle
with holding hands oh geez I'm such a
bad Jew I can't remember the name of it
but it was so fun the fan we all put
yamakas on I I was home it was great
where was it the horror yeah the horror
that's what I called my life stupid I
don't know but yeah
um I even tore a muscle okay but uh had
a great time the chair up with the with
the bride and the groom and the the
woman circles the groom seven times
while the rabbi goes
yeah whatever
I don't think that was Jewish
but it was you know the the the singing
and the whole thing and the Jews are so
funny like all the speeches were killer
the the groom's dead this guy Ben
kirstenbaum funny guy he uh I went with
the wife we did shrooms we had a great
time wow yeah the horns came out now but
um it was so fun and you saved that for
Theo's podcast
um Roseanne's on next week check it out
but uh yeah it was just so fun and the
food was great and the music and the
Hava Nagila the whole thing was great oh
man yeah Jewish weddings can be fun we
don't really go to that many weddings we
never take time off but yeah every once
in a while you're like man it's good to
like live like an actual human totally
yeah was it the Berkshires you get that
drive up it's beautiful the mountains
the Lush trees and everything and he's
just in the middle of nowhere with a guy
on a chair it was so fun even this time
of year but like in the fall when the
leaves are changing oh yeah some stuff
man we're getting old we're having
conversations like this when the leaves
are changing colors I know the only time
we want color all right oh I got I got a
good wreck for you too oh please
burn through this book in like one
sitting basically it's called Uh the
Quran it's killer no uh the uh I was the
SRAM bookstore which is one of the best
places in the city great spot I mean
it's like one of those places you could
just like kill hours
great great spot great people watching
too but uh I'm I'm checking out and as
I'm checking out I see the staff
recommendation uh place and and they
have this book called my lunches with
Orson it's Orson Welles oh and it's just
an interview book which I've seen extra
stuff on the internet before yeah uh
and it's dude it's I've never laughed
out loud so much in my life he's if he
had a podcast right now it would be the
greatest podcast ever because he says
just outrage yes by Peter biskin uh
Edison who made easy Riders Raging Bulls
okay great movie book but dude it's like
you'll never laugh I send you a copy
you'll never laugh so [__] hard out
loud
ever it's like oh really but it's not
trying to be funny he's just he's just
outrageous I mean in the first in the
beginning of the book there's a whole
thing with this guy Henry jaglin meets
him and he's like such a big fan it's
his first movie and he's like I just
want Orson Welles to play this magician
and Peter by Donovan is like he'll never
do it I'm just telling you I'll tell you
where he's staying you could like find
him but he'll never do it and he goes to
his uh he goes to his hotel in New York
he flies just pitch him this movie he's
already got Jack Nicholson and it's a
movie that like did nothing yeah no
money but he shows up and ocean Wells
opens his hotel door in like a purple
pajama set and he said he looked like a
giant grape he just opens the door yeah
this is them together wow it's
ridiculous he's like a monk but he opens
the door and he ends up loving this guy
because he's a very smart guy yeah but
he opens the door and he goes I need you
to be in this movie and he goes I never
do a director's first movie and you go I
never act in that he goes but you acted
in in Citizen Kane that was your first
and he's arguing with him and he's like
he's like I'll never do it under any
circumstances and he goes I want you to
play a magician he goes I know you were
a magician who goes an amateur magician
and then he goes please play this
magician and he goes can I wear a cape
that's all it took he was like that odd
a guy but also he says he's insane
opinions where he just like he says some
[__] that's like kind of bigoted he says
but it's like hilarious sure uh he also
he's also just he just knows about
everything he [__] everyone yeah
they'll like bring up he brings up like
Marilyn Monroe and he's like oh yes I
dated Maryland for a while then it'll be
like you know Rita Hayworth [__] her
wow admits to like cutting her hair
really short for ladies from Shanghai
because he was mad at her so we wanted
her to look shitty on screen Jesus this
I love this old Hollywood [__] dude it's
it's you will love it but I was just
laughing out loud there's so many quotes
there's people that walk into the
restaurant while he's interviewing him
yeah and he's just rude to them like
Richard Burton walks in with with
Elizabeth Taylor and they're like Orson
and he's like can't you see I'm in a
conversation so he's just like rude to
the to everyone he's just uh and then he
would eat healthy at the restaurant but
then go back to his hotel and order like
six rib eyes which is like he's just
such a character and it's like it's
about so much if you love movies this is
made for you but the way he um
the way he made this masterpiece of a
movie at 25 years old he made Jason came
when he was 25 it's like insane you know
[__] up that is to make something that
good it's like what do you do with the
rest of your life it's all down you're
just chasing that yeah yeah I mean
there's a documentary it was on Netflix
for like two seconds about how him
trying to make this movie and it's super
crazy it's a good Doc it's a great Doc
and you see how insane he is insane he's
like let's do this throw this script out
you guys [__] and we're like wait what
you know and but it's worse than well so
they all have to listen to him and then
it just slowly becomes a drug-fueled
psycho thing where one guy dies it's a
hell of a doc I can't think of the name
yeah I watched it was so good but he oh
there's another scene where he's like
there's a woman from HBO and he like
pictures her this idea and she's like oh
I don't really get he's like I'm done
I'm done pitching to you he goes up I
saw I saw the death in your eyes and
I'll never pitch you again he's just
he's so he's he is this awful temper
where he just can't he's totally
eccentric that did you ever see the
critic if you can pull this up on
YouTube
Morrison Wells uh is that was so funny I
was like a nine-year-old like I don't
know if I get it but oh here it is
beautiful can we play this
yeah
man you're right by the way you're ready
crushing Saluki says what it takes this
would have taken him two hours to find
that's true I mean the critic was so
good continue with the later works of
awesome well there's Alan a rich
full-bodied wine sensibly priced at a
dollar a job for a little magic I will
make this jug disappear
grow the next clip
Rosebud yes Rosebud Frozen tea
goodness and green penis wait that's
terrible I quit
just a handful for the road
[Laughter]
there's a french fry stuck in my beard
oh yeah as your family attorney
gay jokes that's true yeah it was a
better time
I mean the critic is Mo it's like all
fat jokes but it's still pretty damn
great yeah and the critic was kind of
fat so you could get away with it damn
this show is good Mike Reese from who
co-created the show you saw all the
stories about him right no he wrote a
thing for CNN oh God I thought you're
gonna say something bad no no no no he I
mean it is bad he was he rode that
Titanic thing
the submarine that went down he was on
that no but he'd taken the same one four
times and he's alive he's alive oh but
he wrote a thing which it's tragic I
mean it's like you know I mean I made a
shitload of jokes about it but it's
still horrible by the way do you see
that Celine Dion's uh My Heart Will Go
On is like it's went up like 800 or
something they're playing the Titanic
Netflix bought it I know it's it's
capitalizing yeah someone had a tweet go
viral it was like I forgot who it was
but it was something about uh if they
just waited I saw that I saw that yeah
it's perfect I could have just watched
the movie but yeah this guy Mike Reese
also I think it was like a season one
Simpsons writer you probably met him
he's been oh yeah I've seen this guy
he's been by the seller before he used
to when I used to have the sage theater
show he would come by all the time right
I mean legendary writer yeah Simpsons
guy and then uh
what is the submarine appeal well he in
his essay he said that his wife wanted
to go it was she's an adventurer and
she's like I want to see it so he went
with her and then they took kova tests
and he passed and she had coveted oh so
he went without her and and he was like
even then they lost tracking like they
didn't know where the sub was sure but
he was on with three other scientists it
was a lot of people like that whoa
because people read it up like it was
just like billionaires was like people
who had I guess you got a lot of money
to do it but
um the site's good you know what do you
what do you get out of it yeah I think
you see amazing stuff down there but
like I'm not [__] rolling the dice no
that was my line I said I don't fly
Spirit you know I'm not doing that [__]
but uh no it's uh
it's it's crazy but he wrote a whole
thing about it being like he knew the
guy and was like he was so safe he was
like this some sort of safety handbook
was his favorite book yeah I mean I bet
you see cool [__] I mean James but then
you see the [__] that James Cameron went
down in because he went down like 30
something times oh yeah obviously way
better yeah he's a nut he loves nautical
[__] I mean he made the abyss in the 80s
never saw that one oh you would love
that's my wreck great movie great movie
uh the girl from uh
Godfather Melissa pastriano super wappy
name what's her name uh she's also in
The Color of Money oh that's her that
was a good flick great movie yeah
there's your master Antonio her she's in
it she's the love interest pretty sexy
uh Bill pack no Ed Harris oh he's a
great movie yeah I love dude Ed Harris
is great and it's when he was still like
trying to earn his keep because he
hadn't had Terminator 2 yet
James Cameron so he was really cooking
oh man yeah I never saw that I got to
see that you know what I just watched on
Criterion which is [__] killer um
have you guys seen early Michael Mann
movie called Manhunter no I've heard of
that dude Brian Cox plays uh Hannibal
Lecter oh wow so it's before Silence of
the Lambs damn it's it's pretty cool
it's a cool there's there's a couple
scenes in it where you're like holy
[__] [__] it's it's legitimately a
scary movie there was a couple scenes
where I was like [__] wait stupid
question is Hannibal Lecter a real
person no I don't think so so it's based
on a book isn't it so wait they're doing
a same character in a different movie no
it was a book and I think this is more
faithful to the book but I think that he
based it on like a serial killer I see
yeah I think he was Loosely based on Ed
Gein
he's also the one that's based off of
the the Texas slaughterhouse or whatever
um he's like a southern fuel killer who
would uh like make like lampshades out
of people oh I've heard of the lampshade
guy all right Ikea before Ikea or Pier
One it's it's a cool [__] movie it's
it's it's legitimately it's that dude
from NCIS too I'll watch anything with a
[__] in it dude he's awesome in it that
sounded weird there's so many
well that one went right over my head
it's so sad because he dies I don't want
to ruin it but he dies in succession the
show's been out yeah people should know
but L.A times with that [__] spoiler
I
that was kind of crazy yeah but I still
I'm like I want to be in something else
because I feel like he's really dead
because that was my in my uh gateway to
Cox wait a minute
no it's uh he's good in it uh it's scary
as [__] it's there's scenes in it but
there's also some scenes yeah that guy
so there's some scenes that are just so
and Joan Allen is in it uh Joan Allen
yeah this is Michael Mann's a [__]
great director yeah very stylized look
at that very Noir it's very Noir
I feel like he peaked in heat after heat
I'm sorry do you see The Insider that's
better than he do you see collateral oh
I did love collateral I got a hot take
for you he's a great movie I take
Insider and collateral over here wait is
is that Insider that who's that Pacino
and Russell Crowe I've never seen it
that's okay that's my record okay okay
never seen it
oh dude the Insiders I think it's his
best movie I think it's a great [__]
movie well collateral is great because
it's got that the the dynamic between
those two guys it's so good so good yeah
it's more than just an action movie I
love heat but I don't think it's I don't
think it's as good as either of these
movies what it's a little long The
Insider watch it tell me it's not better
I'll watch it this weekend I think I
might have wrecked this movie on the Pod
before because my my buddy Craig uh told
me he watched it because of me so maybe
I must maybe it was a patreon maybe it
was a regular but The Insider what's it
about a gynecologist all right it's
about tobacco industry and Corruption
it's really good oh okay really cool
movie Philip Morris
yeah all right watch it and like it's
like a 60 Minutes thing it's really cool
oh Bruce McGill I met him on a film set
I what I worked on a film set when I was
like 18 19. oh in New Orleans well it
was in uh San Antonio of all places you
told me this and uh he was he was
drinking every night he was a fun guy
he's a I think he does like audio books
too that guy's done like every he's been
like everything though yeah I was just
like animal house what was that like he
was like I'll tell you all about it kid
so we just get drunk and be like Belushi
is really that guy he was a mess we did
blow all night wow that was awesome yeah
he's in a ton of [__] still
oh he was just on Reacher which you
[__] hated but stove turned me on too
stav is obsessed with Reacher we watched
that on a ski trip and I everybody's
throwing [__] at the screen I was like
Sam loved it and they're like [__] Sam
he's an idiot we had a good time I only
watch it at the stop but I did enjoy it
it is guilty pleasure it's mindless it's
like the bachelor for guys you know it's
just a big buff dude beating people up
he's got the hot ladies ripped big in a
rip do you see an RFK Junior yeah he's
pretty big he's huge is it not hilarious
that he's like this whole thing is like
anti-farma and I'm like that's not
natural you don't think that's uh look
at that guy you tell me that's [__]
you tell me he's not on something also
we can't get this guy some gym shorts
the jeans workout is kind of badass it
is kind of it's kind of like it's like
an 80s but you tell me that there's no
way this is natural I don't know man 69
years old this is natural well he has a
Kennedy he's got great uh he's got great
yeah I don't I don't remember yeah well
we didn't get to see his uh uncle or
father live this long so we don't know
but that's true that's true they could
be superheroes he is a Hunker but they
weren't like but also body types were
just different back then it wasn't like
stylish reduced it should be true that
shredded isn't that weird you see
bodybuilders in like the 50s and there
there's no definition they're all just
Mass no he does look incredible but it
is also hilarious that they're putting
that scientist next to him being like
who looks healthy I'm like you don't
compare like a rich dude to a just a
scientist no that's true that's like
saying who looks funnier Sam or a clown
you're like you're gonna go with the
cloud every time he's just a normal
looking guy yeah
you know when you meet people they go
you don't look funny I'm like what do
you want me to do have an eye patch and
a bird on my shoulder and a red nose I'm
a human although it is like we I mean a
lot of these dudes get ripped a lot of
these like I mean like Bezos is ripped
Zuckerberg is in really good shape
that's true he does a Jujitsu or one of
those apparently Elon Musk is in like he
doesn't look good shirtless but he might
he's an older guy he might be strong oh
yeah I think he's strong yeah I listened
to some interview with him he was a big
bar fight guy in his uh really College
days yeah South Africa was a it was a
violent place damn yeah
bar fight musk crazy well I think also
there's something to people who keep in
shape there there's something too like
you can't deny that they're
you know go-getters or hard workers or
consistent you know like look he he's
doing no man Albert Einstein wasn't
ripped that's a good point yeah good
point but he's a scientist you let it
slide but look look I mean he still has
muscle under that weird white body yeah
Putin you could tell he works out I mean
you know he doesn't how about that
failed coup in Russia yeah what's that
about I mean Chicken Coop
speaking of you brought up look at that
geez that is a weird shape he's got that
is how men age though we get skinny ass
legs and and guts it all goes to the gut
yeah we don't age gracefully no no
especially shirtless
hey come join us it's a walk-on come on
in to walk on come in hey hey
Christopher Walken
no you're on time
what's shaking what's up brother how you
doing
oh look get that mic get that mic
yes
out of nowhere like he just watched the
special and he messages me on Instagram
whoa so I was talking to Liz now to get
him tickets to the seller
am I yeah let's get him let's get him in
the Knicks yeah I'm trying to recruit
him to the next although I don't know if
that back Court's gonna work but well I
mean I would want
um this guy out of here and get him in
let's just keep Brunson and him RJ RJ I
like RJ but but RJ play good in the
playoffs he played okay but he's uh
who's this Donovan McNabb
he's a stud I will take him I would take
him into you and he wants to be here
yeah he's every picture yeah he loves
New York he's like a meth fan yeah he's
just here yeah his dad works for the
match yeah and his uh
his dad worked for the mess he's a huge
Met fan yeah oh cool and every picture I
see on social media is with like Spike
Lee I'm like you get it it's like a hot
chick yeah doing thirst traps you're
like no we want you too but yeah yeah
yeah no he's great he's great obviously
he shouldn't signed a max deal with Utah
or we could have had Utah well now he's
in Cleveland they traded him because he
got it out but I mean who doesn't want
out of Utah I went to Milwaukee for for
a G uh giannis's brother he flew me to
Milwaukee to do his podcast really yeah
yeah I met him yeah he's great he's
great we hung out and um I don't know I
think there's a chance but to be honest
whoa so I've said this on the podcast
because I did the I did his uh benefit
thing yeah that that has the Minaj put
together so I did a benefit at the
rainbow room oh and be honest comes up
to me and he goes are you a are you a
bucks fan I was like [__] no I'm a
Knicks fan and he just looked like like
this and I was like dude I'm a New
Yorker and he goes well you never know I
end up next free agency and I'm like
yeah it was a lot of that don't say that
[__] to me yeah it's kind of a weird
move like man
we might be drunk fan like no actually I
like uh Bobby Lee's pod like all right
well I might be honor we might be drunk
I made some basketball jokes so we could
tell I was a basketball fan ah okay okay
yeah it was a lot of stuff like that
where they were like you know a lot of
Greeks in New York and we love New York
and I was like yeah I tried to I tried
to call stop because I wanted to
introduce him to style but stop didn't
pick up like I'm like stop stop sneaking
a movie right now he's been a real pain
in the ass okay yeah he's doing Super
Size Me too
sorry he's The Greek Freak well that guy
started to thin mark this could kill
stuff good point no he but I I had
stopped he's supposed to come to the
[__] rainbow room the other night but
he literally did not have one nice
outfit and he was scared he was gonna
drag me down yeah I was like yeah it's a
rainbow room you should probably put on
like maybe a dress shirt or something
he's like dude I don't have any dress
shirts yeah I only have like velvet
it's just track suits man yeah tracks
are Hawaiian and now he's saying like I
want to go to Supply with you let's get
a suit and I was like all right but now
he's like I don't you can't get stuff
out of a story no it's very tough yeah
if you get the suit with him you got to
film it I want to see that tape yeah
really strong Pretty Woman yeah yeah
he'll wear it like with a Hawaiian shirt
on there yeah it won't be what what the
[__] did you just do the smoking oh man
that's great why are you gonna bring a
gas chamber in front of you guys for old
Fashions and I got a couple of nice
little old fashions for you this one is
the campfire old-fashioned wow wow this
is next level can you open up grab one
open up that's great this is amazing
swing that gate open
oh my looks like a science experience
this is amazing you've outdone yourself
beer oh beard you I hear so much about
you finally put a face on it greenhouse
effect right here that's all it is
that's that's what it's here for wow
this looks [__] great yeah so what
did he do anything else with the
old-fashioned with this just yeah so
this is uh this is like my own like
campfire spin in an old fashioned so we
have black walnut bitters we have like a
couple of other uh like extracts in
there a little a rosemary
cheers oh that's delicious the whole
idea is that you're in front of a
campfire with your feet on like a nice
pillowy carpet of pine needles oh I love
this stuff
this is taking me back to when I was at
summer camp
oh yeah stop touching me
the smoke and it just adds so much it's
tough getting a good old-fashioned it's
not as like easy as you would think
because that's your town yeah I like I
like to order I was at I was in DC last
weekend and I went to a bar with uh with
a with a friend and she was like I was
like oh she was like what do you want I
was like I get the old-fashioned she was
like it just depends what kind of bar
you have some bars you can tell they
won't make a good old-fashioned oh yeah
just walk in there and see it but if
it's like a nice gentleman's body yeah
well you've been watching a lot of Bar
Rescue and uh none of these bars would
make an old-fashion I love bar recipes
I've been to like a couple rescued bars
really yeah I've been to like three wow
and then I used to live near one
um he rescued uh The Bungalow in
Rockaway Beach but they weren't failing
they were very successful yeah they just
got um ruined by Hurricane uh Sandy yeah
Hurricane Sandy Rune so he just rescued
it for them it was one of those episodes
where he was like everything you guys do
is perfect just I'll just pay like the
Puerto Rico one
we were fine
[Laughter]
you done that club probably in Ohio it's
the funny farm yeah oh Youngstown that
Youngstown yeah got some bad stories
about that I remember when you played
that [__] yeah they charged me to eat
yeah they go get the swordfish and this
bottle of wine pairs well my God it was
like 300 and I was like that's my whole
check you screwed me funny fast the mark
of a true Club yeah I was charging you
to eat they were upselling me on wine
yeah but is that was it still in the
today when you had to take the elevator
up it was on like the fourth floor no no
because I think they moved it when I did
it they had moved it and the and the bar
at the ground floor was a bar rescue
they were feeling there by and I spoke
to the bartender about what it was like
too oh yeah and what'd he say well he
was like you know it's very reality TV
show like he comes in and he just starts
screaming and you're just like
[Laughter]
a lawyer he did the uh the club in
Arizona oh yeah yeah they filmed yeah
they're done they were they were done
right away he he was always real nice to
me Howard Hughes but he would he was
that type of owner I always liked him on
a personal level but he would go on
stage and do like 30 minutes of like why
aren't you guys drinking more and I'm
like Jesus
yeah yeah and then he would like segue
that into like [__] religion material
and I'd be like you can't be the barkeep
and Bill Hicks you can't do both but
then uh yeah I did that club and then
the second time I worked there uh he
picks me up at the airport and he just
drops me off at like a Mexican
restaurant yeah I was like what is this
he goes oh we're here now I'm like
nowhere in the contract did it say that
we're performing in the back of a
Mexican restaurant it was like a real
like you know comedy moment where I
think it was on Conan the night before
oh then I fly and I'm like I'm
performing in the back of a Mexican
restaurant yeah for three I mean at
least I got free Ceviche hey that's
something that's not nothing but he got
blackout he got blackout every night and
I remember the first night a guy in the
crowd had a [__] stroke wow so I'm on
stage while a guy's having a stroke and
I was just like oh my God are you okay
like call an ambulance and I have to do
this from the stage and Howard like
comes in drunk like I'm on it I'm on it
calls an ambulance Robinson was there
all right sorry the joke was for like
four people all right all right but
Howard goes on stage and starts doing
schtick with the guy who's having the
stroke and goes I've had a stroke before
and I'm like true story Howard had a
stroke from having 14 Red Bulls and
doing a ton of coke it's not as
relatable a story just like a sweet old
man yeah so he's like oh I've had a
stroke before and I'm like dude stop
doing [__] [__] yeah yeah
it was brutal there's a club in Seattle
I'm not gonna say it because it's still
still going I get off the plane you know
a six-hour flight Seattle I'm hungover
it's like an 8 A.M flight you land just
like get me to the hotel worst rush hour
in the country too is it oh with Amazon
and everything so we land and the guy
the owner picks you up and he you know
you want to just take an Uber but these
guys think they're being nice
there's laundry there's kids toys and
all this I don't think they're being
nice they're saving money oh is that
what it is yeah they don't that's not a
kindness of their heart thing I'll buy
the Uber I don't give a [__] it's 28 or
whatever but either way he goes we gotta
make a stop and I go oh geez all right
what are we doing and we had to go to
the Beer Warehouse and load the back of
the truck yeah I had to help I was like
all right so we're putting cases in the
truck
I did the same thing except we picked
his wife up from work and I was like
I've been on an eight-hour flight yes
you're exhausted and yeah same [__] I
remember I remember a couple years ago
talking to you and like we were just
talking outside the cellar and I was
just telling you like all these brutal
gigs that I was doing like a touring
like the Looney bins it's just like not
but I respected you for doing that yeah
I was like but I was like it's it's
tough man I've been doing this for like
five years it's tough to keep doing
these like keep going back and then you
were like no you'll get in like you'll
do some eight rooms and then I had the
opportunity to do the a rooms now and
it's like night and daylight I just did
DC Improv I was like this is the best
thing I've ever done what one of the
great rooms I've ever done it oh my God
yeah it's amazing I went from the
[__] Arlington Draft House to the
Warner Theater oh all right there's no
in between I know but I always wanted to
do the DC Improv just because it was
like a classic room it was the it's the
best corner and then wanted the Improv
it's worth it I know but when you do uh
when you do the Draft House it's like
they give you a door deal and when I
would the first time into the Improv
they expected like we're The Improv you
got to take a pay cut and I was kind of
like [__] that [__] yeah yeah they do do
that is that or The Improv ego I don't
give a [__] yeah yeah they do do that
but you know a mark of a true club like
literally I got off stage and I look at
my phone and I get like an email it's
like the tape of the show oh that's good
immediately I was like all right because
you know some clubs they record it but
they're like you gotta file in paperwork
and we'll send it in the next year we're
gonna go to the guy's house and get your
VHS yeah yeah you gotta transfer it's so
weird when you do a good club like you
go to comedy club on State you ever been
there no no no no no no I know that one
yeah Madison book in yeah yes I know
that's that's a really good one
uh Sacramento
in San Francisco too that's a great oh
that's a great one that's one of the
best rooms and you're an SF which is
great yeah get to go to like city lights
but that's the name of the book City
Lights yeah yeah it's awesome you get
the swan oyster Depot and the dim sum
and [__] I love it right down I mean
it's just so cool to look forward
I mean I was just like fighting crowds
like oh yeah fighting crowds for like my
whole career it makes you worse
but then like you get you're like a
[__] dog that's in the pound and
you're like trying to bite people's
heads up right right with these drunk
hecklers but you're like oh this is
setting me back right I'm getting too
quick to try to throw a punch yes yes
but it is a thing but then you do the DC
Improv you feel like your weights are
off you're just like oh my God this is
like like I've been a crowd that listens
this is amazing you got to do Matt I
think Madison might be the best yeah
it's like I heard so many good things
Comedy Works right that's okay no I
actually I did Denver Improv last time
which is notoriously known as being a
bad Club but they were Under New
Management like I can't even it was like
and when I did it it was great I was
like why do people [__] on it they were
like no this is a new owner that like
yeah
[Laughter]
oh that's good to hear because that was
the urban room yeah yeah it was there
yeah so yeah we were all in the hockey
room I uh I heard a story there I won't
say the comic but they were like he was
on stage and the mic cut off like a
couple times like when he was on stage
which is like you should have that fixed
right we need one thing yeah yeah you
should have the microphone but uh at the
end of it it happened like a couple
times and at the end of his set he was
like that the mic didn't work so if you
guys don't want to pay your bill don't
pay it and like half the people just
didn't pay that bill whoa and it cost
the club a manager told me across the
club like twenty thousand dollars whoa
did they take it at his pay no they were
like we just we just took the hit like
we just kind of we like they were like
going back and forth with like the
management was it a pretty successful
comic if I if I tell you all fair you
would be like yeah that was him
yeah
wait was that it bleep that wow that was
a guess so you do it as DMX or Jay Z
I guessed it first guess yeah first guys
damn I've heard a million stories about
that guy yeah but damn thank God we
bleeped it
so you the this is gonna be blue yeah
all right so yeah it was him wow
he was like you'll never guessed I was
like was he black he was like yeah I was
like boom easy
[Music]
what a rep so the specials on HBO yeah
and that's the one Donovan Mitchell Saw
yeah yeah I believe that Comedy Central
I did The Comedy Central I did a half
hour for conversation they put it on on
YouTube yeah I know that's the only
place it got watched
um which is good but yeah the the HBO
thing when it was on HBO Max it was like
on the top of HBO Max for like days
which that that helps like these
celebrities they'll just watch it like
yeah it's super cool so yeah so I got to
like I when I went to Milwaukee like the
national like he picked me up in his
Rolls Royce I was like this is insane
like damn he's like you gotta come you
gotta come to the the grease seems like
come you'll stay at our Villa we'll fly
I'm like wow
it's insane is there a little part as an
introvert I it's all cool and fun but
then you're kind of like can I go yet do
you have any of that or is that just me
part of me yes but the other part of me
is like I need the story man this story
is insane like literally we were at
dinner like I don't even know if
whatever but we were at dinner and we
were talking about he was like you got
to come to Greece I was like I would
love to go to Greece like that's right
places that I want to go he's like yeah
we that's like we run Greece and I was
like oh yeah like I want to go and I was
like oh you have to go to Dominican
Republic which is where I'm from I was
like you're going to love Dominican
Republic he's like yeah he's like you
know I'm in town for two more days I'm
not kidding he pulls out his phone he
calls like his Jack guy he's like did
you could you find out how much is a jet
to go to Dominican Republic tonight wow
and then he's like all right let's just
go back to dinner and I'm just sitting
there like am I gonna have to cancel my
yeah my weekend to go to Dominica review
yeah I would have had to like they're a
looney bin yeah
yeah I would have had to like that's
insane it's just a whole [__] wait
dude
that's insane how the other side lives
yeah ridiculous I don't know if that's I
mean that's awesome but uh like Sinatra
used to do that like ah [__] it we're at
the casino in Vegas I'm bored let's go
to London we'll get on my Jet and I'm
like I don't know if that's good like
it's it's too easy to do stuff and then
it all gets boring well come flying with
come fly with me it was like come fly
with me was like a big thing yeah right
travel is like a new cool yeah yeah come
fly yeah zones yet he can go anywhere
that's insane like that that like to me
it was mine by like to just your life
like that like I know we're talking
about private travel when you're wearing
a [__] Aaliyah shirt right now
I mean flying is like those private jets
I hate little commercial planes yeah but
those little private jets oh yeah you
flew private right both of you yeah yeah
but I mean you know it's it's scary
sometimes it is yeah it's also scary I
was on a private jet once but I believe
it was uh it was Sandler Judd Spade Rob
Schneider I'm like I'm not even in the
first [__] two paragraphs yeah Adam
Sandler and friends yeah which is how
they build the show but you know
yeah that's tough yeah but that that's
that's sick I never been on a private
job oh you will be yeah that's that's
amazing like when I see people post
photos I was like could you like so I
mean I've had this conversation with you
like this the success that you guys
reach is just insane like this is just
something you just started to do or you
was like Hey I want to do comedy and
then you're on a jet with like five of
the biggest yeah it's insane I know I
mean think about all the Jets I mean
you've been on a bunch right yeah I was
on a helic the helicopter scares me more
than the jet the helicopter just because
like [__] Kobe one of the celino and
Barnes guys there's people that just
yeah real drop-offs yeah by the way when
that happened they had new Billboards
like the next week where it was just I
think Barnes doc it was just Selena like
the next week they completely was like
all right we gotta get new
and his daughter was fighting him for it
because like he took him off like the
entire thing he like took over the whole
yeah it was like a Greek tragedy that
only New Yorkers give a [__] about yeah
or it was a setup
peel your dick off your leg I guarantee
I'm wearing them right now I'm not even
gonna look
see that dick there we go come on
come on where this summer switch to
sheath sheath underwear keeps things
Breezy down there with a pouch for your
dong and a pouch for your balls you'll
be comfortable no matter what the
weather is available in tons of cool
patterns tons of colors feel great and
show off your sense of style it's all I
wear I throw all my other ones out they
all have skid marks and [__] stains and
crusties they stay good I mean I love
the Uniqlo ones but let me tell you
something they turn in a Swiss cheese in
a [__] week and a half two laundry
roads roads Jesus Christ we've been
drinking that was terrible I apolog two
laundry loads oh that was Asian that was
offensive yeah especially with Uniqlo
Jesus Christ I am I am feeling very
upset but let me tell you something
those sheath underwear they're top-notch
I'm a big fan sheet was made by US Army
soldier Robert Patton if anybody knows
anything about tough weather and sweaty
conditions it's definitely this guy he
was out in the desert with an AK
shooting who knows who stock up on
sheath and support a veteran-owned
company while you support this podcast
we didn't forget about your sweaty
boobed listeners ladies summertime can
be brutal for you too check out cheat
sports bras bikini briefs boys shorts
keep it Breezy and trendy go to
sheetthunderwear.com boy shorts use uh
promo code Kevin Spacey
[Music]
go to promowship.com promo code drunk
to get 20 off your first order plus
sheets underwear is 100 money back
guarantee that's sheathunderwear.com
promo code drunk get cheat done aware
support the show and support your balls
great the best underwear
I really do love it honestly I know
we're [__] drunk here when you're
showing off that summer speed or the
last thing you want is a dirty butt
crack you can spray all the cologne you
want but nothing gets you cleaner and
fresher than the hello tushy bidet I
love a good bid day it washes your butt
with clean fresh water for a better than
toilet paper feel could ever give you uh
the hello tushy bidet cleans your bum
two times better than wiping and
prevents poo particles from spreading to
your hands and touching everything you
touched you want a woman to stick a
tongue in there you better clean that
butthole bar it's we'll cut that part
leave it in okay leave it in it even
attaches to your existing toilet so
there's no additional electricity or
Plumbing needed it installs in less than
eight minutes is that eight yeah that's
it cuts toilet paper used by 80 good for
the environment yes call Gretta she'll
be happy and pays for itself in just a
few months I I love bidets or something
about it I don't do I can't go back to
toilet paper I like the cold water the
hot water any kind of water just
spreading my ass crack I even come
sometimes after taking the [__] just
shoot a hot load all over that toilet
seat bar you're both spraying yeah go to
hellotushing.com forward slash drunk and
use promo code drunk for 10 off plus
free shipping on your first bidet order
that's hellotushy.com drug for 10 off
hello turkey.com drunk
see how it goes all the way to the top
damn it
I thought we didn't know a elevator we
did a helicopter in Australia it was
pretty fun it's a great way to get
around yeah
it is dangerous too right like it's not
it's like relatively dangerous for air
travel yeah more than planes for sure
yeah but little plane still I mean look
I'm I'm not I'm a pretty good flyer you
kind of have to be to do this for a
living but uh yeah the plane starts
shaking sometimes and you're like it's
tough yeah I went I was just I went to
Dubai and I did like the 380 which is
like with the biggest commercial of
airplane you literally don't feel
anything like you right it just takes
off and if you don't look out the window
you just don't know what's happening
that's true and that's insane some of
them now have showers on it that one
yeah
now that I've never seen yeah shower bar
the Singapore Air I look like to look up
fancy first class yeah Singapore
Airlines they have like you could get a
hotel room like like it's kind of like a
room
has that bit about it right you know
about uh the shower and the and the
because you have to like book out your
shower you can't use too much water it's
a whole thing oh is it yeah yeah that
seems like one of those things that
you're like is this necessary I know
there's like the shower in the lounge
you have you been in like the American
Express like this showers you're like
who's using this yeah people are [__]
in there that's I think that's it yeah
that would that would make sense so
people who just are like on an insane
travel maybe it like it wakes you up but
like I I used to think like who the [__]
are these showers in the theaters for
and then I was on a tour bus and I was
like oh they're for guys like us all the
time oh do you yeah I use them every day
for like 10 days yeah the price are
fully loaded you're on a bus so you get
to those theaters and you're like oh get
me in that shower I've been hanging out
with you know Joey Diaz
it's kind of spitting all over me how's
the bus life that sounds cool that's
like that's like like summer camp [__]
like dude I mean before you guys and I
saw you go play basketball I was like
every day we play every day I rolled my
ankle in the last day but I was doing I
was that was like it sucks because
that's like the day you're like I'm
[__] I'm back I'm feeling it yeah the
Jumper's finally going yeah yeah and
then you [__] roll your ankle and
you're like I'm too old to play yeah no
I don't know if it was you or maybe Gary
posted something where you were running
and I kind of saw like it then I was
like oh [__] same place like yeah like
you could tell about how you move I was
like I used to play well yeah I stink
now but I I uh Jewish lightning
well that was the most fun is like you
just go you end up in these like pickup
games on the road and you're like the
best part is this one dude in Portland
was like I'm a big fan and then he's
like so he's cool to me but then he's
like he's I'm gonna guard he guards my
tour manager he'll be nice to me but
he's [__] he's like bumping yeah yeah
poor manager in a way where I'm like
this is a fight's gonna [__] right
right because they'll be cool to you
yeah but then they're like no I'm gonna
[__] up your friend yeah yeah my manager
is like Brian's kind of a [__] he
won't back down like he's he's a dude
that will throw down sure and it got to
that point where I was like [__] this
could get ugly yeah sometimes if I can
break out the [__] YMCA in Portland
yeah because I do that sometimes on the
road I'll find a gym and I'll go play
like pick up but sometimes you just want
to kind of like shoot around and they
take it so seriously like yeah you're
like I just want to shoot I don't get
hurt yeah but then right because you
only know one speed because you play
like Pride takes over right Pride takes
over yeah my neighborhood yeah
but yeah yeah for sure I remember I was
in like Kansas City and I went to like
the thing just to I honestly just wanted
to shoot around and they needed like an
extra guy so they asked me and I was
like yeah I'll play and I'm like I'm
just taking it easy I don't got good
sneakers I don't think but they start
talking [__] and then immediately you
start like I start I'm like I can't do
this I have shows tonight yeah exactly
we played in Seattle and this guy was
such a [__] [__] yeah at first it
was a friendly game but he started
talking so much [__] to me that on game
point I [__] like elbowed him off and
then I pulled up on a three in an hour
ago night night and I drained a three on
them I was like you turned me into an
[__] yeah yeah yeah yeah I said night
night to it dude yeah that's good that's
a good move
I like that move man yeah I used to play
when I was in high school and my my
school was like ranked in the nation we
were number six Whoa We were the worst
[__] school in the country super
competitive so like that competitive
thing comes out but I broke my ankle now
like I don't want to play anymore I just
want to chill out I can't be breaking my
number one injury also sucks is you guys
are public figures so you're out there
they can be like yeah it's uh Class Act
yikes
they have [__] on you now because you
don't know this is just some guy in the
Y yeah yeah but it's usually just a fun
game it's usually a fun game and also
you score a couple times and it like if
you score on them they don't matter what
they say you could just be like you're
like my son you're like
you're like my kid it's also just like
the best way to exercising the road you
stay healthy every day I mean we would
drink pretty much every night but then
during the day I'm like I'm [__]
sweating I feel good yeah good by
Showtime every night that's the thing
when I first started going I remember I
used to like was I used to when I used
to open for you it was always fun to
hang out because when I started going on
the road like everybody who I opened for
was like now sober and they were like
they were like if you would have came
five years ago we would have partied all
night and then I'm like I was like 25
years old I'm like all right I guess
whatever they're like eating healthy and
they're sober but and then I went out
with you and you were like oh no we
could drink till five in the morning we
went to it we did a gig at a roar at the
casino yeah oh yeah drinking all night
yeah oh we gambled yeah we gambled that
was right before I did it man yeah
Springfield Mass right across from the
Basketball Hall of Fame we went yes it
was fun but you you were on a tear you
were you never played blackjack in your
life yeah and I won like six seven
hundred dollars killing it beginner's
luck we're all hooting and Holly he's
the only Brown guy in there it was good
it was it was fine yeah that was the
weekend before I did The Tonight Show
well he wanted hard yeah that was that
was there you are that was you at the uh
he was all puffy from uh drinking he's
got beautiful eyes look at those eyes
oh my gosh I'm going back there yeah I'm
doing it with the eyes of an Angel yeah
the green eyes the diabetes
oh that's Jimmy Dunn yeah you remember
we did we did uh we did a heart we did
Bridgeport oh night and then in the next
morning you were like I got covered I
think I had it yeah I kicked it one day
I just I just sweat it out
that's you're lucky that's all you got
him bro I'm there in two weeks
I'm doing stress San Francisco
Sacramento which factories is that's
that's a root that's a room I mean like
the club is good it's the Sidious yeah
the city's better yeah they all Drive in
you're gonna get at least one show where
you get the biggest [__] Heckler who
just won't stop and bring a camera
because you're gonna get some content
yeah some lady yelling at you charging
the stage whatever
that's why I got chased off stage that
place you got chased off at The Bijou
Theater not the but it's in Bridgeport
yeah yeah it's a [__] done they got
on stage out of theater yeah
wait what this was years ago this is
many years ago I told you this story
okay yeah I I mean it was just an animal
[__] dude just like a linebacker
heckling me the whole [__] show and
it was like 25 in I finally just like I
put him down every clever way you can at
a certain point you're like I'm out I'm
out yeah [__] off I had nothing so I
just said you were Neanderthal you're a
[__] and he stood up and I was like
he's [__] enormous he starts walking
through the stage like six six built
like a linebacker just like a like scary
looking Italian type dude yeah he starts
trying to I'm like well someone's gonna
stop him right he just starts climbing
the stage I'm like [__] this [__] so I
just I had the mic I just like run off
and I'm like I'm not gonna [__] fight
this guy so I'm hiding in the back and
some woman is yelling at me to get back
on stage they had to lock the door
because he was gonna try to get to me I
was like I'm not going back he's a
[__] animal yeah throw this guy out
insane so it took like seven or eight
minutes but they're like booing me
they're so mad about the show and I'm
like I mean this is not not a great gate
to begin with but yeah I'm like this is
a lot whatever so they finally get rid
of that guy after she was like scolding
he's like you have to go back out there
and I was like [__] this crowd [__]
these people and they're booing so
[__] loud I'm holding the cordless
mic so they heard my entire interaction
backstage they hear me acting like a
[__] they hear me calling this city
garbage and I have to go back out and do
the final 30. and it sucked so that was
one of the worst what that was one of
those this is why Dave Chappelle brings
Buster Rhymes to open you know somebody
comes on stage you got a crew well that
he won't he has issues with Connecticut
Rogan won't do Connecticut it's true
Chappelle won't do Connecticut yeah yeah
you got a point man that's brutal get
with the mic on that almost seems like
unreal like a movie yeah it was it was I
know it's like how the bad guy goes down
in every [__] movie yeah the bike was
hot the mic was uh the Durst yeah yeah
you're the what's the what's that movie
Robert Durst the Jinx the Jinx you're
the Jinx it's like every movie they're
like we got that on tape you know it was
humiliated and it was like not a lot of
money but the time it was a lot of money
there's a beautiful theater too is it
yeah I mean it's like one of those
old-timey movie theaters where like you
could see a comedy show but you could
also see like Casablanca oh that's right
yeah it's that level tiny theaters like
that but yeah the city is Connecticut
it's just kind of broken because you're
either in Dawson's Creek or like the
wire you know it's Bridgeport or was
Dawson Connecticut
maybe it was in like South Carolina or
something no but they uh he's right it's
like you're either in Greenwich
Connecticut like the disparity of well
Bridgeport which is one of the word like
the poorest oh yeah well not whale yeah
but that's what they filmed it is that
what the actual show takes place
no I don't think they filmed in
Wilmington they had to film in La
probably really uh probably so much [__]
is filmed at Wilmington now North
Carolina growing up in rural North
Carolina oh yeah yeah so much so much is
filming yeah I mean they filmed I think
one of the Iron Man movies there because
if somebody's made some issue with
Atlanta and then Wilmington cool City
yeah I'm doing Wilmington
that's a good rope yeah I
[Laughter]
um one time I was in Vancouver they film
a lot of stuff there that's true I was
in Vancouver and they were filming uh
Deadpool like that like I saw a Deadpool
like he was on a bridge like he was just
like yeah like filming that's cool yeah
it's cool when you see these things
Vancouver is another one Deadpool is
[__] good yeah great comedy great
action but then they tried to make like
every character like that right they
were trying to be like the witty super
yeah yeah it worked for him and Iron Man
that was it right right yeah Spider-Man
had a little bit of zing in him but he
was wholesome yeah he was a nerd uh I
was on the Benjamin buttons set as a PA
really oh yeah they filmed in in New
Orleans I was in New Orleans for that
[__] oh really yeah it was like oh five
it was right after Katrina yeah so the
city needed money they're like film here
we'll take anything and so we got I got
David Fincher here I got Brad Pitt I'm
like a kid in New Orleans my hometown
they're [__] Brad Pitt's 10 feet away
from me was so cool that's insane but
that made no sense it was filmed like
they added the Katrina element to that
movie and it made zero [__] sense of
the plot she was just like drowning in
Katrina during I'm like this adds
nothing to the story yeah yeah there's
no timeline but the whole city was so
[__] up I think they had to do
something because it was so run down but
sometimes I think it's weird when they
don't even acknowledge it a little bit
like because like I you watch friends
friends was running during 9 11 and it
uh oh yeah the first few seasons is all
scenes of the twin towers and then after
that they're just like they didn't like
it came back in 2001 they were just like
that's a good point not one single thing
Handler's just like could this city be
any more
[Laughter]
[Music]
is this an old-fashioned as well this is
an old-fashioned high ball so like the
first one was a little heavy it was a
little strong a little a little smoky
this one's like a little pal cleanser
all right nice
um you're killing it it is funny yeah
like succession we were just talking
about that before and and that show
didn't acknowledge kovid which I kind of
appreciated you like it I kind of like
yeah you can see a Law and Order and
they'd be wearing masks and you're like
I don't want to watch this [__] that's
true yeah that seems but lawn order is
supposed to be happening in real time
that's a good thing right that's like
yeah you literally see it like you walk
down the street you're like oh you see a
bunch of cop cars like oh that's just
Law and Order yeah right right you're
right Colin Quinn's always like they
never put me in that's like his big
gripe I don't think he's like he's like
I've accidentally stumbled yes yeah
they've never cast me yeah which is too
cute like yeah you should be in a lawn
order yeah yeah he's a legend but that's
the thing about Mulaney that's like
Mulaney has the quintessential Law and
Order bit that will just be there for
all he does yeah he's got that he's got
the Trump bit I mean I would love to
have a bit like that where you just nail
something and every time you think
what's bit I feel like you're early
[__] bit your [__] bit is bad thanks
yeah that's Timeless that was like a
long way but you're not a dig begin a
topic God that's true so you have points
that are great points but you're not a
digging the topic like yeah Millennia is
like a seven minute Law and Order you
don't have a seven minute chunk right no
no but then like even but it doesn't
have to be a dig in like Todd Berry has
that great bit about a neck tattoo he's
like whenever I see a guy with a neck
tattoo I always think you forget I
forgot
and every time I see a neck tattoo I
think of that [__] yeah yeah yeah I got
a great Todd Berry basketball story
don't tell me he's good I know there's
no way yeah but we were in Montreal and
Blake Griffin was there oh that year and
uh and Blake Griffin is like he sees top
Harry goes holy [__] is that Todd Barry
shut up he's a comedy he's a comedy so
he's freaked out that so I tell Todd him
I dude Blake Griffin was shocked that it
was you and like every year like once a
year Todd Barry's like you know Blake
Griffin was Star Struck by me yeah yeah
I'm like I told you that story
unhealthily oh it's so funny it's yeah
it's but you it is true what you said
like when you when you see these guys I
have these Chunk on bits and you're like
did they just sit down and come up with
this it was just like like did was it
carving away like and you kept adding
things like a Gaffigan or something yeah
yeah Hot Pockets I mean that's in there
forever you you I saw you do yesterday
you had a great one with the WNBA line I
won't give it oh you were in the room I
was like that's good
you were like that keep that that's I
have only fans for guys is our WNBA like
nobody wants to see it yeah that one's
great I got a big pop oh that's a good
angle that's fine I ran that by a couple
guys and they were like I don't know
maybe and then you liked it so that was
the only thing that kept me going you
know when you're a bit is new you have
no confidence in it none at all yeah you
know and you're so insecure about it
like maybe I'm stupid
I mean but it's interesting to me that
people thought that wouldn't be good
like that's just like a clearly like a
great analogy I've had that a lot
actually people are like I don't know
about that one and then it'll hit
why did they say that they were just
like I don't know maybe something there
it like they they weren't giving me any
love on it so I was like maybe maybe
it's not anything because I can I can be
influenced very easily about my [__]
being bad yeah you know one guy's like
I'll read a comment one guy was like you
do this for me a lot and I was like I do
and I went into a shame spiral in my
apartment yeah that happens to me too oh
really yeah it happens to me too which
is weird because part of me be like
because when you see these comments
you'll be like I wish I want to see
these people in person because like I've
never met somebody in person who was
like digging me and I was like and I
felt the way about it right I was always
like what like what are you like so
these people but you can't get back like
if you engage is like for what because
you don't know [__] about them yeah you
know you should be able you should have
to post like a photo of yourself
right next to the comments yes like let
me see what you look like you fat people
right now yeah now now let's go back and
forth yeah because I was putting my soul
out yeah yeah you seeing everything I
got yeah but you know what I mean it's
hard I mean the jokes just take a while
so yeah that's why you need to run them
by only your close friends at first to
get that that like oh this is something
because sometimes you take it out too
soon and it's a bold premise yeah and
the crowd's like what the [__] are you
like oh it wasn't ready for a crowd I
need to like sculpt this a little more
yes yes right but I mean I mean come
like when I started first of all when I
started comedy I didn't know much about
anything I was just like I'll figure it
out I knew that New York was a place to
start and I'm from New York so I was
like I'll figure it out and then as you
go on you do another open mics like I I
ran into you and you and list and one of
the things that like I kind of was like
okay I want to be like this like this is
what I want to do is like when you're
coming up with jokes even if the joke
isn't good and if it bomb it's a joke
yes it's not like there's a there's a
mounting and there's a Dismount all
right it's not a like a
what else do I got Well yeah if the Joe
bombs it bombs it's fine but at least
there's like the work is done yes it's
set up in a punch the sometimes
mathematical yeah sometimes I see the
comics where the work is done and it
makes me feel like but you didn't do the
work like that you just you're just
using me yeah as like the work do it
right right like you're fishing you're
like anything there yeah yeah it's like
do the work I'll tell you if it's good
or not you know as an audience that's
true well you're like a definitely like
a clear-cut joke guy and that is Mark
and I've talked about this like when we
would do mics that is actually harder at
Mike's as opposed to the people that are
finding [__] yes when when it's like
yeah silence yeah and it's just a bunch
of jaded comments yeah yeah yeah and
also I remember early on like I kind of
got labeled as like a go like you used
to think like I was like a go hard like
oh it's because I use it because because
I used to like come with jokes and have
fun they're like why are you going so
hard at this Open Mic it's just an open
mic like why you care so that's
hilarious I wanted to do well like I've
always wanted to do why are you doing
the job how hard it is something that a
lazy person will label someone who's
giving a [__] to make that's himself
feel better about being lazy absolutely
it's like a dude hustling in a [__]
basketball game like why are you going
for the loose ball yeah and I'm trying
to win do you win the game yeah it was
it was tough for me like because when
open mics like after doing them for a
little while I kind of was like I was
like because you know you run into so
many different personalities I was like
I don't see myself in any of these guys
not any of them like I had the ones that
are still working I was like okay me and
them but most of them I'm like I'm
nothing like this but then you move up
and you mean other comics and you're
like oh I'm like this like I do things
like this 100 but uh but yeah I remember
those days was tough and it's not just I
like this guy's act you can see like oh
he's obsessed with comedy as well he's
working hard as well he's doing a
million spots as well right like I did
New Zealand and I went to all the bar
shows because I had a couple nights off
and you want to meet the local guys you
want to see what their scene is like and
uh there was this one guy who was just
at every bar show and he had new [__]
every time and he was hustling and I
brought him on the theater I was like
you want to do five on them that's the
thing yeah people respect the hard work
yes more than like anything like if
you're like oh you're doing what I'm
doing all right I'll give you I'll give
you exactly I see the go hard I'm like
let's reward this guy yeah workout we do
but we spoke about this I'm not in that
too cool for school club no I hate that
too cool like yeah who like take they
take rejoice in like bombing I'm like
I'll bomb on my own yeah the bombs come
yeah I don't need to try and we bonded
early because I'd be like oh that
Gaffigan bit you're like I love that bit
yeah some guys are like I don't watch
that [__] you know you're like well wait
you don't like comedy yeah I do
sometimes go through phases though where
I can't listen to Comedy I get yeah I I
don't want to be influenced but I was I
was doing a lot of like long drives this
week because of you know the gig so I'm
like [__] it let's put on Sirius XM a
Neil Brennan bit would come on and be
like [__] that's really good yeah bit
would come on an old Chappelle bit and
I'd be like man but then you get some
other guys some of these Comics I'm like
this is [__] horrible more bad than
good a lot of ones I was like let me
give this person a shot and I'd be like
nope yeah nope yeah but then you hear
like a Vecchio bit and you'll be like
this is [__] this is like a hard joke
yeah you know yeah it that's it that's
very interesting because like a lot of
times the guys even the guys that you
that you might think like are horrible
they'll like kill too so yeah it's true
people were laughing doesn't mean I'm
laughing I know I know yeah yeah or that
it's good right but it's a good point
yeah and there's a lot of the same [__]
you just hear again
the topics over and over same topics and
the crowd work
is getting so the same I don't want to
get into it because I know there's a lot
of people out there who
they're gonna you know feel this but
hey what are you guys up to uh you guys
Dayton that's my daughter oh that's my
favorite porn site
is just so four years ago dates and
dates come up
hey we all got to move tickets
and look there's a lot of those and Mark
and I we talk about crowd work a lot
because Mark and I we do it like I do it
all the time I'm trying to move [__]
tickets same yeah but yeah this try to
go a different way yes you're doing that
I'm against unoriginality what's your
name Kevin of course it is what does
that mean his name's Kevin that's what
his mom name do what do you mean you'd
say that for any name yeah yeah I I I I
I have like a I feel like my perspective
on um crowd work even before the clips
thing like I always thought that crowd
work was inherently hacky like it's not
in a bad way but it's just like you ask
the same things and as a comedian you
kind of all go through the same but you
try to do your best to be as original as
you can like yeah and some people don't
even try that right right just like how
do you think you're staying crowd work
is a thing like of course we're funny on
our feet we're professional Comics right
the written bit is much harder and I was
always working toward the written people
like for crowd work it's like all right
I'll do an hour or something on stage
I'll do an hour 10 maybe and then three
minutes two minutes of crowd work yeah
and if I get a funny moment I'm like
I'll burn that because I don't want to
burn up the joke same but and this
amazing crowd work out there like Todd
Berry's grade yeah is great I mean bag
kills it there's a lot of great crowd
work yeah there's and there are original
ways but yeah you have to make sure not
to fall into the tropes that are just so
[__] yeah it's easy you have to like
it's sometimes the first thing that pops
into my head I'm like don't say it yeah
yeah yeah the other thing is yeah think
of something else yeah there are
original ways for sure but even like the
guys you've named I've seen them do
crowd work where I'm like I have heard
this sure because inherently we're
asking the same questions and you
finding like the quickest thing the
funny but you said something one time
that I was like oh yeah that is true
where you were talking about like
getting into it like you want to ask
original question questions right but
like getting into it like the where you
from what do you do how long you guys
been together you have to get into it
that way you can't just be like what's
your favorite sex position you know like
you have I've seen people do just
straight into that yeah what do you do
you sit down the first date like you
like anal yeah right right
yeah I'm proud you can do that like
stops crowd they're ready
they're prepared even stop will kind of
like massage it starvel kind of what do
you what are we doing here we're getting
[__] lit up what is this
ladies man Leon Phelps what is this
glass
I forgot about the Ladies Man underrated
movie yeah good movie I worked with him
oh yeah for him yeah El Paso yeah he was
it's funny he was like uh like ever like
he kind of was like like mean to
everyone but he just took a liking to me
so so like anyone wanted to talk to him
they kind of had to talk to me like he
was like talking to him unless it's the
woman he's like oh it's a lady yeah yeah
he's good Tim Metals yeah I forgot about
I don't know I think he quit no he's not
he's still reacting and [__] still no I
mean stand up he was just when I think
you should leave season three all right
yeah Tim Robbins and shout out to season
three he's great we went to see a game
we was we was in Texas we went to the uh
to see a game at El Paso what the
college I forgot the name of a UTEP I
think
um and uh and all like he's in um
Mean Girls oh he's great all the white
girls just kept coming up to me like oh
my God are you the guy he's hilarious
yeah it was right he's great in that
movie yeah he's a great actor yeah he's
the Grove I've done the girl oh my God
and uh remember him in uh that John C
Riley Walk Hard
oh yeah oh my God he's [__] funny in
that moment did you ever think you'd be
doing the same rooms as Tim Meadows like
I was a kid watching this guy on SNL and
now I love rooms and what you're doing
theaters let's be honest
I've been all I've done all these yeah
you did that you did that yeah Side
Splitters Side Splitters is the class
many times
great Club but he's out there I played
Side Splitters for like over 10 years
yeah I love them yeah it's home
I'm doing uh I'm doing so I think I'm
doing the Grove I mean the the Wesley
Chapel one though not the not the oh
yeah yeah new the new rules the movie
theater one yeah yeah which I've done a
couple movie theaters once we can be
good yeah yeah it can be good if I feel
like the Acoustics in the movie theater
are not bad for comedy definitely who's
the person that you work with like
coming up that you're like holy [__] I
can't believe I'm opening for this
person yeah
uh
um probably I mean when I opened for Tim
Meadows that was like a big deal because
I was like ladies man like that was
really cool I was like all right I want
to make sure I get a photo
um but but comedy comedic wise in that
time like 2016 2017 like when I got to
work with Norman it was like oh my God
because he was just not like my idol but
he was you were just killing it at that
point like I feel like everybody has
this time and especially when you come
up in New York like everybody has this
time like right before you reach the
next level where you're like you just
every room you're just killing it in
every room like people don't know who
you are that much but like every room
you go into there's a couple people and
they're like you gotta watch this person
I'll tell you one thing fun about being
at a like a theater level is you get
this you can see down and like oh he's
gonna be there you can see who's working
hard and who's who's killing and coming
up with original [__] and you can kind
of tell like oh him or her is gonna pop
the gift of seeing down that's important
like when you have it to like impart
that on people because you know when
you're coming up you're just like should
I just quit
I thought that every week yeah so when
people give those compliments it's nice
but yeah when I got to like when I got
to work with them it was just like I
remember that time it's like when you
got no credits just like a comic you
think is funny telling you that a bit
was good that'll keep you going for like
two years oh hell Mark turn me on you
dude I mean Mark was like you got to see
this guy I was like oh let me watch him
he turned me on he he wrecked me at the
cellar The Tonight Show like all those
things like it was just like if you're
working hard you got jokes why the hell
not yeah yeah it's it's funny because I
feel like in in the younger guys scene
you kind of have a reputation of like
Mark hates everything and I was like but
he he helped me do this
do you have that you know to me she
doesn't have that well I hate the hex
you know yeah yeah so but Mark's also
like you know he's passionate he's you
know yeah yeah but Seinfeld that's what
they say about abusive boyfriends yeah
yeah
I'm like he loves hard he loves hard
that's a good movie title he
just loves hard
he said yukana was like that for him oh
yeah that's right I love ran on and uh
yeah I mean he was just going so [__]
hard I mean he killed his [__] were
original his uh
his his killing on stage was like yeah
on a level that I was like oh [__] this
is like yeah he's next yeah yeah yeah I
mean just work on the person out
everything yeah a little Charisma come
on now he's just his jokes are so good
yeah it was just like I went to his
taping and I was like holy [__] this
guy's murdering is that what's that one
called Live From The Underground yeah
that's a great special I mean he really
uh he was coming [__] hard on that
one yeah he is he always does that's
like he's always been like oh yeah no
he's uh I think I wrecked him at the
seller if I'm not I don't know I think
he did yeah I think he said you did yeah
I did actually yeah yeah I got a good
track record there dude I got him I got
Dina and I got
I'm producing her special that's going
to be out uh September I believe on
Amazon so keep your eyes out for Dina
December 11th my birthday yeah yeah
um yeah who so Dina Rana and I and this
is a weird one I wrecked James matter
and years ago there yeah because she was
like I need a host and uh I was like
James Mattern it's like so long ago and
she was like huh and Ryan Hamilton and
Nikki Glaser at the table and they were
like yes James Madden like Nikki goes
best host in the city you know yeah I
love judge she brought him in to do a
set and it didn't go well no yeah and I
was like come on like trust me just let
him host and then years later they
brought him back so that was my only one
I didn't get passed yeah he did warm-up
for my HBO
he can just go like in his energy he
doesn't have to stop talking yeah you
can just go I got a reckon which is I'm
like fairly new I've only been there
like three years so the fact that he
will even take my recommendation
which wasn't a hard sell I read Marcelo
he's on SNL
yeah
and uh and I jumped on Sean Murphy oh
yeah yeah Rick Sean Murphy he's funny
I think oh nice yeah nice Sean Murphy
yeah check him out he's got a special on
YouTube called Neil funny guy good job
do you have an actually like a pod wreck
oh yeah yeah because yeah I had a wreck
it's funny I didn't know this was gonna
be but I actually got gifted one of
those smoke things for for the whiskey I
was gonna wreck that like it's like a
smoker thing but it's for like an
at-home bar so I do it like you it's
like a it has this little thing and then
you put what do you put in it what's the
things put like a cedar wood chips so
wood chips then you burned and then I
got three different flavored wood chips
and then you burn them and then you put
in your whiskey and you can have a smoke
that's a great wreck I'm gonna get one
I'm gonna get one yeah put it on Amazon
pull it up there Peters we actually have
some right here this is like a cooking
show yeah
uh let's see who sent this to us we got
oh he's so incentive in nice yeah we got
we got a couple of them
QR says want one tree heart
yeah I don't know these are actually
really cool this is the same style that
most of them are it's called a volcano
smoke yes yeah you just put it right on
top of the glass yeah they put the wood
chips in here you light them up put them
up it was a Christmas gift it's great do
you do it for just regular whiskey or do
you do it only for like a Manhattan or
an old I do it straight I do it you
could do it with anything yeah with a
regular whiskey or whatever whiskey with
the with the uh ice that's it I was
gonna do it for like all three of you
guys but it'd just be like awkward to
put three of them out so I went a little
fancier with you guys but uh uh but yeah
no these are these are really great like
any kind of volcano they're called
Volcano smokers all right okay yeah good
crack yeah that's a like if you have
that if if you bring a lady over and you
pull out a volcano smoker that's a game
changer and it's it's super easy yeah
and it's not easy she's like what they
get dizzy from the smoke also like what
you got to do is you gotta get the
Golden Torch like you get these golden
torches yeah like a little butane torch
like this but it's golden like the like
Nick cages golden guns yeah that's what
we have at say less that's how we do it
and is that face off yeah oh no yes yes
I was on TV the other day that's a
[__] great movie great great action
movie it's just so Tom and great yeah
way over the top
I mean it makes no sense yeah it's still
great and if you guys see the new one uh
The Unbelievable way to yeah yeah
yeah I enjoy they make a golden guns
reference there you go you didn't like
it
I watched on a flight it was fun that's
a good playing movie yeah better than
Final Destination
which I've also watched how to play I
watched Babylon I've flew Australia so I
watched babylon's good I watch yeah it's
great I watched the Malaysia missing
plane dock on a plane really yeah why
would you do that to yourself
yeah easy cheer yeah they're gonna come
after you
do you see that [__] yeah I was with it
I was with her when it happened oh
really yeah we were doing a corporate at
Gotham where she was like she was
literally sitting next to me she was
like I think I'm getting canceled right
now and I'm like what are you talking
about she was like no that she was like
I'm getting these Malaysian hate things
I think they did they're like secret
services like searching for me and I'm
like it's Malaysia that's not real and
then it was real he didn't find their
plans they're gonna find you yeah yeah
it was real her Instagram got
deactivated
I didn't know that yeah but not not
Instagram they reported like like enough
people reported her page for like hate
speech which she had to she fight it
back now it's insane it was just yes I
mean we think we have a bad here and and
then you see I know that's true Malaysia
is a really crazy like internet police
like cyber security police that they
just started a couple years ago it's
intense and especially like they even
like because like a majority Muslim
country it's like a lot of pornography
it's not like it's not like Saudi Arabia
Muslim but like the majority of the
people that are Muslim and the
government kind of like
goes towards that so like they have like
really crazy internet police all right
well keep making those cheap
[__] cause I'll buy them Malaysia I
support you it's a [__] good place
though she's not even Malaysian though
she's from Singapore yeah uh yeah well
they're they had to call like it was
like a diplomatic like they had to call
in diplomats yeah
are we getting nuked no a comedy routine
has gone viral yeah yeah and it's not
kind to us I think the seller took down
the thing they got like 5 000 negative
reviews
I saw that which it's like guys yeah
they had to I did a Dalai Lama clip you
know when he was licking kids or
whatever and all these uh Dalai Lama
people were like how dare you blah blah
and they would share it and go don't
follow this guy I'm like keep sharing it
get it out there and by the way if you
do that you just have to write we're pro
kid tux tongue sucking because yeah
that's what he said maybe that's a joke
I don't understand but it's not my humor
yeah
uh either way you'll be real popular in
China now yeah yeah well it's a hot
video either way it was yeah do you guys
have wrecks
we I had one before we got here about uh
this book Orson Welles uh my lunches
with Orson in a movie called a Manhunter
Michael Mann from the 80s yeah [__]
incredible I'd never seen it yeah it's
just like uh
man great soundtrack great score yeah
scary as [__] yeah just a cool movie I
got a wreck and a non-rec well did you
watch the score of the Schwarzenegger
doc no I'm it's on my cue though it's
fun just to see like this guy [__]
made it from a farm in Austria to like
the biggest guy on the planet which is
crazy to watch but he doesn't come off
great why well he's just super cocky and
at one point he gets he's in the
bodybuilding competition and he tricks a
guy and he goes hey good job you're done
and the guy was still his time was still
being counted so he walked off stage
early and then I won so I'm like you
kind of [__] over your friend yes he
talks about beating uh the Kennedy lady
whatever her name is River Shriver and
uh his the mom comes over like my
daughter wants to meet you and he goes
she's got a great ass and the mom's like
what I don't know he doesn't come off
great and well I mean he did impregnate
his maid yeah
he's that's all in there but he is a
[__] Legend he's a legend I I loved
him I mean he was a big Hummer guy he's
all over the Hummer you know and you're
like well those aren't goodies he's also
he's also doing a lot of good [__] for
Jews I mean like really oh man doing all
the advising anti-Semitism he gave this
great speech about the night of broken
glass in Austin I thought it was pretty
yeah yeah he's he's very articulate I
mean he was a [__] Governor true have
you have you uh done comedy in Israel I
have and I would like to yeah I did how
was it toured through it it was great I
mean for me it was great I was like the
guy the fish Auto you know that when you
get that push of like he's not from here
so we're gonna listen more uh the Exotic
novelty the novelty yeah it was it was
amazing I did like Seven Cities I did uh
I did Tel Aviv I did runana I did base
shemish I did uh Jerusalem I gotta do
that yeah it was great I'd love to do
that too we should do it should we do it
we might be drunk
Tel Aviv is the biggest Party City that
I've ever been really it's I mean it's
insane like it's like girls gone wild
like what yeah wow okay we gotta go
let's do it well here's what I don't get
about the birthright let's do like a
[__] co-headlining thing and see if
we can I would love to it's a big open
what is it 20 hour no it's 10 10 hours
oh really we should do that all right I
want to go to Israel I've never [__]
been look yeah the Tel Aviv that's what
it is yeah and it's just the most
beautiful people I've ever seen like
yeah doing sit-ups dude do women demand
everyone's shirtless like they're just
beautiful people how much I have to
exercise just to not be a fat piece of
[__] was how much we drank I mean yeah
yeah yeah but you know Matt Ruby has
that great joke but every time people
come to America they get ruined like you
go to see Jews out there they're all hot
and sexy and ripped yeah and then here
it's just like Woody Allen you know and
then the Greeks well you go to Greece
Greece it's all these hot cool guys you
know they're swarthy and sexy and then
here it's just Diner
but yeah wow look at that they don't
even know we're not doing our people
proud over here no we really are but
look at these these people are good
looking yeah I love staff man stop was
one of those people like we kind of
started off like at the similar time and
like he's one of the people you just see
immediately you're just like this guy's
hilarious I like like just immediately
fun it's like just so funny
yeah yeah oh yeah he's yeah it cleans up
yeah I got I got um he asked me to come
uh work with him when he was doing uh
The Wilbur and so we hung out that
weekend and it was just I'm like stop
you've built this life that you've built
is just amazing amazing you and your
boys like it was like Elvis yeah it was
Elvis it was no like it was in Rockstar
like we did two shows we ordered like
Thai like a feast between show so we
just did a show and it was a Thai feast
and then we just ate like [__] Kings
and then that we just did the show and
then that was it like that was just rock
star lifestyle and he'll go eat some
lady's ass later too you know good for
him he's killing it he locked a tooth
with eating [__] you know that helped
that was he's the first person to lose a
tooth and helped his words it helped his
swag yeah didn't give a [__] most people
were like oh my God my face and he was
like yeah whatever no yeah I saw a bunch
of girls at the stand one night and they
were raiding who the hottest comics and
Stavros got in like he got in and I'm
like he was top 10. wait what they're
like there's something about him he just
oozes and I'm like he's oozing grease
yeah yeah well my niece she works at the
stand she's a she's a waitress at the
stand and she sends me like photos of
stops she's like I love him I'm like
he's naked on he's eating Chinese food
on a car hood she's like nah I love him
though I mean I love him too yeah like
he's got something yeah he got it he
figured it out man when you're yourself
that just being yourself is like the key
that's one of the cool things about
comedy is like you know some Comics will
say crazy [__] they're like [__] this
guy he's a piece of [__] and then some
Comics will say crazy [__] and they're
like but you can see he's a good person
he's like yeah he's I mean I I had
conversations with him while I'm like I
had to kind of fight back on how liberal
he is where I'm like stop that's a
little far I'm like you're getting rich
the socialism [__] ain't gonna fly
anymore yeah
yeah
well yeah there's that great Oscar Wilde
quote uh be yourself everyone else has
taken yeah that's that's like so true
but comedy is so hard to be right
because you're just like you see [__]
Melania you're like I just want to be
that I know I have that bro that's why I
don't watch a lot because I want to just
keep my [__] blinders on and just be
who I am and I I it's so easy to get
influenced even on like a you know
subconscious level yeah Cadence could
influence you uh uh a premise so it's
like yeah I try to distance myself from
Comedy but every once in a while like I
love comedy I want to watch it totally I
I saw I heard Joey Diaz one time he was
saying that he saw Mulaney and he was
like I want to be that I saw that clip
you you're like so far off that and what
you do is so you like but you see it you
see it kill you just get like of course
I saw Melanie do new in town I was live
I was there I went because I was a fan
and I brought a lady and she was like
who's he like I [__] you yeah it's great
yeah and he's like a cute clean cut guy
and he's murdering I still think it's
his best work yeah and uh I was like I
gotta be more like that yeah but that's
not that's not true but you think that
in the moment yeah you do it's hard
there's certain hours you just can't top
you just put so much blood and sweat
into that [__] it's just hard yeah I'm a
big I'm a big believer of that where I'm
like when you hear comedians talk
obviously you're trying to plug
something so you're always like this is
the best thing I've done but it's like
yeah
that's not that's not true I got this as
my best special by far I think do you
what what's your best special I mean I
think out to lunch but I ran it for four
years so you can't compete with that
time you put so much [__] out to
lunch is the is the one you did in La
yeah the big YouTubers most people say
is the is the Schumer one for you what
yeah like people say oh that one I feel
like has a lot of holes in it but I'll
take it I'll take it like on the road
like when you hear people they'd be like
that that was like wow that was so good
like wow that was your one too Schumer's
one I did one for Schumer yeah that
wasn't I got this no I got it I did
positive influence oh that was a seller
one yeah yeah I think that was my best
I've seen both positive influence is
great I think I think they're both there
I think they're Pokemon like yeah
they're both like I was just joking for
jewelry and Hungary when I did I got
this I was kind of yeah no one will buy
this [__] yeah that's the same thing
like when I got when I finally our
careers mirrored each others yeah we had
Amy both producers I know and I know you
guys will remember this but I remember
you told me that you guys were gonna
release on YouTube like and you guys
worry about it and I was like it's the
way to do it it's gonna it's gonna
change the game wow
I know I was like it's gonna change the
game you guys but then you also started
a president of like everyone thinking
they could do it but it's like well you
have to be talented and good well we we
also hit at the right time there's a lot
of factors going on yeah right there's a
lot working for both of us with those
releases right right yeah and the talent
that's like important what were you
gonna say about the HBO
Oh I thought you're going to say
something about yours your thing no no I
was I was saying get back on you no I
was just saying that uh yeah like
positive influence and I mean but
they're all great like like one time I
got stuck at the cellar with Louie which
was random like I just not stuck like I
was sitting there and he just walked in
he blocked the door yeah he just he just
sat at the door you sure are pretty yeah
he just sat at the table it was just me
and him talking for like two hours
talking about me just one-on-one no
interruptions it was amazing and and I
kind of got to like pick his brain and
like talk about it and he's like yeah
you don't just get better there's no art
form where you just get better like you
get great and then you get your fans and
they'll always follow you he's like I
always told him he told me he was like
he he doesn't think he'll ever be as
good as he was in 2009 I think that
shoot up no he said it wasn't even a
special I think it was chewed up but he
said he he rewatched the special uh a
tape not even a special just a set that
he did in like some Brooklyn show yeah
and he was like I'll never be as funny
as this WOW Patrice said the same thing
but she's like I'll never be as funny as
when I was like 19 yeah yeah because he
was like I had to be funny no one knew
who you were you had to work the whole
room yeah oh I was gonna say about you
you said you were so angry
um the the the when I got uh when I
finally did new faces I was so angry
that I hadn't went and all my friends
had one yes yeah like when I did this
like you're supposed to do like six
seven minutes I blew the I did like 10
minutes where I was just like like I was
trying to like level them yeah like I'm
here yeah it was like what the [__] and
all like I had yamanika hosting too and
she I love yamanika but like on the
intro she kind of got me more mad she
was like this next guy like I don't even
know why he's doing it like he ran over
from the seller to do a spot on this he
should have went years ago she did like
a three minute intro she was like you
guys are ridiculous like this guy should
have been waiting and I was like yeah
yeah that's great yeah all right yeah
yeah and then it was a hot crowd at New
York comedy club and I just [__] like
I just like I did like 10 minutes I
murdered I just left like I was like I
don't even want it yeah cause you don't
need it yeah yeah I'd say yeah I got it
okay
like I'm going this me too I'm doing
like are you there Wednesday the 26th
yeah yeah you want to open my show sure
yeah yeah let's do it I'm doing variety
I got comics to watch oh hell yeah
there's a step down my show I'm sure you
know uh no it's gonna be cool but uh
what room do you know I don't remember
but it's uh but it's they have such an
ego Montreal and there's a lot of things
where I'm like I'm happy to do it but
the ego to me is like this isn't 1994.
yeah you're not doing your festival and
give me a sitcom yeah not even [__]
want one so it's that thing where you're
like hey who cares festivals to me are
so overblown and they're so they're so
to me they're just fun to hang it's fine
they're fun that's all they are yeah
other than that I'm like I don't give a
[__] yeah I'd rather just do my own
thing yeah Festival you feel like you're
you know I'm taking a shuttle you're in
someone else's Mercy you gotta get a
badge I'm like wait what the [__] is
this [__] I I mean I in hindsight though
like at the time I was like miserable
and every time that the list came out
and I didn't get it I was like I don't
know what I'm not yeah
not really we got over that quickly yeah
but in hindsight I'm like I'm so glad
that I got it like organically like I
was doing it for 12 years like I've been
doing comedy for 12 years I've been in
New York every night like any New York
Comic would if you ask about me they'll
be like oh yeah he's been here yeah he's
not like that's the one I think yeah
yeah I remember the first time I did The
Tonight Show you I think you messaged
like you told me that like somebody
brought it up at the table and everybody
at the table was like yes he should get
it he deserves it and to me that was
like bigger than doing The Tonight Show
of course the fact that my
contemporaries agreed that I deserved
that opportunity I completely agree as a
guy with some success to me the people
go what's the biggest moment in your
life whatever was your big thing it's
being able to go hey let me get this
show in Chicopee going and it sells out
immediately and you can work out
material that's number one Comfort
Comfort but just being like I can go
there I can work out and people will go
buy tickets you know it's not like you
got to promote you gotta just paper half
the room it's like it'll sell out you
can work out you can stress are
promoting it never goes away yeah but it
goes a little away yeah I mean like look
they keep booking you in bigger venues
you're like [__] I do a morning thing to
promote this I gotta do this I gotta
keep posting and [__] but like you know
you'll be okay and that and Jesus Christ
what are we doing this right you got a
like a three-course meal here that's
what I'm saying is dessert right here
what is that this is a little another
Riff on an old-fashioned
[Music]
you gotta make it look pretty you know
yeah so it does look very nice a coupe
glass the Peach on there yeah and the
stick maybe your best work of the whole
episode oh the closer Jesus Christ this
is Mariano Rivera a little burnt brown
sugar on top of the peach
there you go man
man Jesus Christ all right I'll get to
that in one minute just going to clean
this oh I love it it's great unreal yeah
you're an artiste I remember speaking of
this remember watching comedian as a
young comedy I watched it 800 times on
it's on Netflix now
ornie was going like uh I wish I could
be like a public figure I wish it could
be a celebrity I just want the celebrity
and I'm like I remember thinking you're
in every Club in New York you're running
around you're doing Letterman like are
you you're still upset you ungrateful
[__] yeah but but then you kind of go
through it and it doesn't go away right
like I I you know I'm in every Club no
no and then you look at the guy and
you're like damn you sold out how many
shows yeah oh dude Jerry it still hangs
on the [__] that you're like that still
pisses you off yeah same with rock I
remember reading an obituary for Lucian
who is the booker at the comments and
they asked Chris Rock what he thought of
him and he said the the quote he gave
was something along the lines of well he
passed this guy and not me oh and I'm
like you're Chris Rock and you still
hold on and maybe that maybe you need
that uncomfortable he's still a human
maybe you need that fuel we're just
wanting to kind of put on Bookers
because it's like I I don't have that
because I'm like you're allowed to make
mistakes like you're allowed to be wrong
on your pick you're not like I've been
wrong how many times you've watched the
draft and you're like this guy's a short
thing and then he's not yeah you're not
an NBA Scout but they're not a comedy
Scout either
okay I mean I've got an elite room in
New York they should know better
I think I think so too yeah interesting
I think hacks win sometimes and I think
look looking at hacks is short-sighted
it's like the guy with all the hype who
doesn't try that hard it's like a guy
it's almost like going with a guy who's
got no ceiling but is flashy right now
as opposed to someone where you're like
this person could grow into something
great yeah right I think he's a Booker
you do have a responsibility to invest
oh I think so too but I think it gets
muddied a lot yeah because they're
businessmen especially now with like
social media now they're like you got
how many followers yeah you're past oh
that's very muddy yeah it gets muddy but
if it depends what you want to build if
you want money do you want to build a
great Tick Tock comedy club or do you
want to build a great Comedy Club but
it's also you got to keep the lights
that's what I'm saying some of the club
is like well I need to stay open yeah
this guy's gonna fill it up so give him
a Wednesday night yeah yeah there you go
you don't have to give them a weekend
yeah that's the thing when I first like
when I I mean I've been on the road for
like a couple years now but like after
the special when I really wanted like a
set of tour and get out there like a lot
of the offers were like one-nighters and
I was like no I don't want to do a
one-nighter like if a club doesn't want
to like invest in a weekend in me then
fine that's what I'm saying Vivian Laura
the weekend and give uh Harry The Tick
Tock star yeah whatever I'm making up a
name here yeah yeah yeah yeah you got to
throw it back you know that club that
always used you and believed in you uh
yeah go back and sell out a weekend in
five years when you have it when you can
move tickets yeah yeah I'll come back
yeah I I always yeah I always like was
like you know what if the club don't
want to do it like whatever like I
sometimes I mean like I'll talk to
Comics who are like they're like you
know when you're not really selling
tickets like that you go on the road and
you do a club and if you don't really
sell out you kind of feel bad but I
always remind myself I don't feel bad
like I didn't sell you you didn't you
didn't pay me like I was supposed to
sell out your club right you got to sell
out a club you get a fee for selling out
the club you paid me the basic fee for
being a professional comedian which is
what I am I've done all the things I've
done open mics for years I've done The
Tonight Show I've done Comedy Central
I've done HBO so this is it like you're
gonna get a good show whether it sells
or not I want to sell but if I don't I'm
not like
but you're grown yeah and yeah and it's
each year is going to be better than the
last for you that's that's I it's been
like that so far I want to keep it tell
it yeah yeah Rolls Royce pick up at the
airport yeah that was pretty cool
that was cool that when I was in that
Rolls Royce I was like I understand why
some women are gold diggers
[Laughter]
it makes sense yeah you're like I feel
safe yeah stop your head from going down
you're like what do we do yeah
yeah for sure yeah that was a good
experience that was cool I mean I keep
doing every time you know when you're
coming up you do these cool experiences
and you sometimes you gotta like you get
home and you're like I can't believe
that was a thing I did well I would say
the best Comics have that uh you know
when you get checked you know like let's
say you became a zillionaire and you're
just like [__] it I'm in rolls royces
I'm getting blown every night I don't
need to go up but your friend goes hey
come on man what are you doing you got
to go up you got to go up but the best
Comics have that guy inside they have
that check guy like David tell he kills
he walks off stage he's like how the
heck I suck and you're like are you
kidding you're a genius you're the
funniest guy on the planet whatever and
he's hilarious and he's still he's
probably got 20 minutes on the submarine
thing you know well that oh now you you
asked me what was the guy I opened up I
opened up for a hotel like two years in
oh I did I did a one I did a I hosted
like one night at like bananas on like a
Thursday and and they saw me and they
were like Jersey yeah yeah and they were
like they saw me and then the next
morning I get a call they're like we
want you to come back and open for a
towel like I'm a new I'm like two and a
half years in that's a nice moment yeah
and I'm like are you kidding me like you
guys like me yeah come open for a tub
but they were like but the only thing is
like you gotta be completely clean like
no cursing nothing dirty completely
clean yeah and I was like no problem I
was like whatever you guys want I'll do
it so I go I do the show completely
clean is is fine bring up a tell he
murders in between shows I'm talking to
a child and I'm like yeah you know we're
just talking about comedy I'm like yeah
it was a little difficult because I
couldn't curse at all he was like why
can't you curse I was like the club told
me to be clean and he was like they told
you to be clean for me and I was like
yeah they said not that not to be dirty
for you he was like for the second show
add a curse to every punchline
[Music]
[Laughter]
I was talking to my [__] mom
and not a great sign for the club like
come on let the guy no but now I get it
though now that I headline I get it
though because you tell a new comic you
don't you got to tell a new comic that
because sometimes they go up there and
they just cursing aimlessly that's true
like it's just aimless put an open mic
who's doing like bits about like you
know getting pegged or something yeah
yeah
you just started it just opened up I
jizz on Betty White's corpse
this is a bit about 7 45 yeah we don't
understand why you're [__] on her
course it doesn't make sense yeah no I
remember we did uh
Joe Mack and I when we started we did a
class at the comic strip and I remember
he made us work clean and it was good
for us and I remember asking him like
well David tell's not clean he goes yeah
but he could be yeah that was his
favorite tell can work clean yeah can
you not yet and I was like okay
I think that's great advice for like new
yeah new comic like if you get clean if
you could kill for 15 minutes for clean
you would work like pretty quickly yeah
look at pretty quickly yeah you will
work yeah yeah with Seinfeld calls you
better have that clean [__] yeah yeah
now I do like I'll do like corporates
and stuff it's like because like when I
did the when I did Fallon the first time
I wore a suit when people weren't
wearing suits but like I was like I want
to wear a suit because I want to have
this clip of me wearing a suit yes doing
silent and I feel like that's gonna lead
to more stuff right good point and then
I did it and then covered hit and then
the whole uh like George Floyd thing
happened where like so it was like a
cultural revolution
so like every business was like all
right we got to get a black guy now and
then I had this Tonight Show instead of
me and a suit so they were like this is
him this is looking safe
so I got so much work after that so much
work I was doing corporates I was doing
like honestly like when when Kobe like
in September I was doing like three a
week wow wow they're gonna be like I got
an ad for Men's Warehouse
I was [__] killing the corporate game
I did a corporate for Pfizer
wow you're getting early vacs yeah no
you know what's funny like my agents
were negotiating this is like after the
vaccine came out like you know your
agents are negotiating and my agents
just sent me the email of like the fires
are guys saying like uh our budget is
kind of tight
and we're like how many vaccines
everyone's looking for a discount though
you're throwing out the world you're
really jamming me here yeah
uh specials on HBO you got uh a ton of
give us some tour dates coming up yeah I
mean I'm in a Bridgeport uh I've been
doing uh the stress Factory in uh two
weeks I'm in Chicago in September doing
Zanies nice uh Springfield Mass uh
Seattle San Diego doing The Comedy Store
in San Diego oh you're gonna [__]
love it doing live Boston at the end of
the year Detroit uh Houston at the riot
the Wesley Chapel the whole thing
Wilmington go to the website what's the
website.com we didn't even get to do
[__] oh [__] you're right it flew by
yeah all right well yeah HBO special
Comedy Central special check out his
YouTube it's all up there and he posts
Clips he's on Instagram the whole doing
my best yeah we got Montreal Ian Lara
opening oh yeah
uh yeah uh Providence Northampton uh
Burlington Albany uh Bethlehem York
Toronto Chicago Theater [__]
Phoenix Cleveland Columbus Cincinnati
Indianapolis Pittsburgh a ton of [__]
see on the road samrill.com shows hell
yeah get some Bodega cat and uh I'll
I'll be on the road as well big European
tour coming I'm going to England
Scotland
uh [__] Copenhagen uh but before that
I'm in Nashville I'm in the Hamptons I'm
in uh I'm doing that phantom power I'm
trying to run this new hour but then it
was cool big theater tour uh you don't
say it's uh it's all up on the site I'm
coming to La San Diego
uh [__] I can't remember if Houston
all the all the big ones all the fun
cities so check what's the name of the
tour you don't say I love it yeah uh
Louisville whatever it is it's all on
the web website and yeah check out our
specials oh it's on YouTube uh yeah and
one quick thing I'll say it afterwards
but yeah you guys we love you guys uh
beard you Peters uh Bodega
catwhiskey.com you have a plug oh yeah I
actually have a bigger plug coming out
uh next month we're gonna be coming out
with the we might be drunk cocktail
recipe book oh the cocktail book so
everything that it has been like all the
most popular cocktails obviously the
pair of plain with a lot of the other
Classics and also all beer gee Originals
including all the three old Fashions
today we'll be in the book oh great and
these were Stellar so keep an eye out
and uh it'll be like a nice cocktail
book and also you can uh drink along
with us beautiful all right great what
were we gonna say
you guys the best we love you
[Music]
dangerous
out to lunch here in New Orleans this
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]
we might
be true
[Music]